[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you dare enter this house
it's Tuesday [ __ ] it's been a week
system on the phone election and you're
still crying get over it go bring back
the dress you bought for the [ __ ]
after-party that's the problem you
worried about the party you weren't
worried about the [ __ ] important
things got something rule number one
worry about what's in front
uncle Joey here Tuesday November 15th W
kHz the Duchess station burning on some
leftover [ __ ] Russians you got your
[ __ ] references like a [ __ ] kid
that's not baptized in limbo just
walking around everybody's [ __ ] crying
the zoo is even empty only tears on when
their zoo is empty you know there's
something wrong with Gentile see let it
go let it go Hitler's he if the devil is
here whatever [ __ ] you want to call but
enough with the political science course
let's get down to smoke there's some
reefer that's why we all showed up
now the lung is on fire today you
understand me that's right what's with
the [ __ ] chatter chatter let's get
down to smoking reefer that's why we all
showed up here it's [ __ ] Tuesday
morning what do you want from me
everywhere you turn people crying you
turn to me we have a good [ __ ] time
you know why did you don't need to give
a [ __ ] about this stuff just stuff
that's around this is your [ __ ] world
this circle right in front
everything beside that could suck your
dick or all this cuz I'd be able to
think it's love you behind that desk at
the end of the day it's you [ __ ]
dignity but simplify it that way me I'm
just gonna keep smoking my reefa
cracking stupid jokes until they put me
in a [ __ ] casket that's how I roll
I'm just happy to be [ __ ] alive
everything that's I'm a lot of people
who [ __ ] didn't forget I'm just happy to
be alive with my two fat [ __ ] fungi
to help feet get that carpet in the
morning I say lord thank you for giving
me a [ __ ] day almost these
[ __ ] give me the strength to walk
around a bunch of men like a [ __ ]
giant and that's what [ __ ] happens
alright and beside that that's it I'm
stoned to the get up and busy this
morning I've been getting on I all
[ __ ] morning I'm worried about little
Joey you know I got it under control
I love this reason I don't want a drink
I don't want to see celebrities I don't
want to mingle in the VIP lounge I want
to smoke right here and then got the
good and evil when you crazy
[ __ ] I consider family
understand I'm with you you're with me
and they want to be with us until that
point [ __ ] [ __ ] if I'm Santa
as long as you look at that man in the
mirror and go today I'm gonna give it
110 [ __ ] percent nobody's stopping me
they gotta shoot me with a [ __ ]
bazooka you understand me
that's that's your [ __ ] mentality it
all starts right here everything else is
background music you control life for me
but you control your own [ __ ] destiny
understand you gotta be honest with
yourself you gotta smoke weed and be
brutally honest I'm ugly I'm fat I'm an
ex-con I'm a [ __ ] loser
I had dirty jobs who gives a [ __ ] you
keep getting up and go on every morning
who's gonna stop you who a president
stop making [ __ ] excuses for yourself
and get out there there's the United
States of America you could plant your
own [ __ ] flag yeah and you want
to [ __ ] cry go ask these [ __ ]
minutes are not obedient see if they're
[ __ ] crying to me there may be crying
they may be taken out of here by their
[ __ ] hair
but that's the way life works out shout
out to Puerto Rican Nelson it [ __ ]
little story last night you haven't
heard the podcast it was a funny [ __ ]
podcast Leslie break the Simmons's he
brings the [ __ ] down I love that but
beside that that's it that's that I want
to do Jitsu I'm going ahead do the final
edit on the special and I got a spot at
the store today I got to do a little
right when I got to pick up the girl
from school and who's better than you
you got it under control brother the
controls touching your [ __ ] head who
you're gonna hang out what were you
gonna eat were you gonna deal with oh
you're not gonna deal with them where
you gonna end up
anything a black get make it too much
but I'm thinkin I goofy you think I said
he a confusion [ __ ] they [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you actin [ __ ] being Confucius you act
you get in there you get on that [ __ ]
farm you need a job [ __ ] but who
gives a [ __ ]
[Music]
it's not holidays mother what if you're
not making work now again that's setting
up 2017 you're [ __ ] slipping they
understand me but enough is enough
I should to do and people to see and I'm
stalling for the gills why why you know
I [ __ ] keep doing this to yourself I
love you [ __ ] the podcast is
ready for you next Wednesday night have
an Earthling Friday night used to Texas
papacito's [ __ ] Papa those [ __ ] him
Chuy's get ready Carabas will come to
Houston Jack big I'm not even I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm not even gonna eat there his
name I'm just going to Houston to
[ __ ] eat the shows at 10:00 then
we're gonna have a good time that's it
but next Wednesday's good next
Wednesday's the night before
Thanksgiving an Irvine hmm but the line
up together gonna have a good [ __ ]
time and beside that I'm stoned when you
offer me at least we got this little
time to pay take' one another that's
always very important
we touched base with another let each
other know how will feel let each other
know that were [ __ ] making it today
everybody's gonna suck
I love you oh yeah my mother completely
get it didn't come out of dual sorry
they're given to my mother - I don't
bingo wire my position though your
course I'm Tony or so called rope beer
illegal Asante see my pal
let's go alive Bobby all right
[ __ ]
have a great day and nobody to stop you
with you alright stay black the podcast
tomorrow 8 o'clock